aujourd'hui spécial invité dans le
studio pour vous annoncer une excellente
nouvelle c'est arielle ariel avec qui je
travaille sur un projet depuis quelques
temps ariel gomez qui a un média qui
s'appelle retail numérique
[Musique]
non
m
tu peux nous présenter déjà retail
numérique savoir qui tu es ce que tu
fais alors est-elle numérique magazine
est un magazine qui s'adresse aux
professionnels de la vente de produits
high tech c'est à dire là où vous
achetez vos produits fnac darty hall et
les agences orange bouygues et sfr etc
donc on les informe sont les nouveautés
produits et sur les marchés et sur les
tendances bien évidemment tu parles
professionnels toi ouais les a faits en
bref est ce qu'on appelle le 'b to b'
mise tout mais ça veut dire business to
business donc ça concerne le business
entre deux entreprises et moi ce que je
fais c'est du gui to see business to
consumer redon cas réels en retail
numérique magazine
il fait du bouton me tandis que moi je
vous parle à vous directement sang soit
plus du tout si bon et après si vous
voulez vraiment vous amusez vous avez le
'b to b' to see mais là par contre on
commence un petit peu à complexifier les
choses qu'on fait le contact entre les
constructeurs globalement de tous types
de produits de tele2 téléphonie bien sûr
d'accessoires et ceux qui les vendent
donc on les sait que j'ai dit à l'heure
de les informer sur les tendances on va
sur les salons en fait on fait un petit
peu la même chose que qu'aurélien honte
est un peu moins deux pro vie c'est un
peu moins d'autres trucs mais par contre
on a un petit peu partout et on essaie
d'être le plus en avance possible sur
les tendances pour informer la
distribution donc son appel le retail de
ce qui va venir prochainement
voilà ramadan cette photo regardez-moi
ça la réelle voilà c'est bien moi que
reste-t-il alors on voulait vous faire
une annonce aujourd'hui parce qu'on
travaille depuis quelque temps déjà sur
un très gros projet sur lequel vous
allez intervenir alors je te laisse à
représenter introduire et puis complète
on explique alors ça va être une grande
souvent avec beaucoup de vernis way
d'une soirée sur la téléphonie mobile à
laquelle on va faire venir
les opérateurs les constructeurs les
rites et leur donc les distributeurs de
produits
les gens qui font du reconditionner les
accessoiristes en fait tous les acteurs
de ce marché à la fois pour les
terminaux et pour les accessoires pour
avoir un débat à la fois donc un débat
qui va être là en partie soit 5 g la 5g
c'est la prochaine génération de
téléphonie mobile
vous gérez vous allez avoir des débits
absolument fabuleux en trois secondes
vous allez pouvoir télécharger vos
séries donc ça va arriver en france mais
un petit peu en retard il faut dire en
suisse a ouvert en grand bretagne a
ouvert où s'est ouvert une antenne pays
en 2020 c'est en commençant tout cas ça
va commencer en 2020 et quand il sera
vraiment un vrai marché en 2021 mais le
but de cette soirée si l'un formé un
petit peu tout le monde et surtout de
créer le débat entre les professionnels
pour savoir comment ça va se passer
qu'est-ce que vous aurez comme produit
qui est ce que vous aurez comme service
de la par les opérateurs
où est ce qu'on va pouvoir acheter des
produits à quel prix etc etc etc elles
seront tous les tous les impacts sur le
marché donc c'est ce qu'on va chercher à
expliquer c'est une grande soirée en
fait dans mon milieu professionnel donc
malheureusement vous pourrez pas être
présent physiquement le jour j alors
vous inquiétez pas il y aura un vrai
reporting vous saurez tout je vous
raconterai tout très peu de temps après
mais là où vous allez intervenir avant
c'est qu'il va falloir que vous puissiez
voter c'est vous qui allez je viens
parce qu'on va remettre des prix ce
seront les grands prix les grands prix a
entraîné des plaintes de rds et ça
effectivement on va vous demander de
voter on va faire une sélection avec
aurélien ayant pas consulté pour cela
aussi tous les acteurs du marché
ouais une sélection de smartphones
d'accessoires d'offres d'opérateurs et
où on vous demandera de choisir celles
que vous trouvez les plus intéressantes
les meilleurs celle qui vous plaisent le
plus et sur la base de ce ces votes là
nous allons décerner des grands prix et
ses grands prix seront décernés au cours
de cette soirée marc et donc c'est vous
qui allez voter trois ans vous verrez on
en parlera dans quelques temps
le vote aura lieu au mois de novembre
pour tout le mois de novembre les
pouvoirs vous choisir récompenser les
marques les opérateurs les smartphones
va vous faire explique à tous un peu
plus tard mais c'est vous qui allez
faire le vote est ensuite les les awards
les prix sont de
et directement aux fabricants aux
opérateurs se seront issus de vos potes
donc ça fait vachement vachement
vachement intéressant surtout c'est un
truc qui est nouveau il y avait déjà eu
une soirée comme ça mais c'était autre
chose il ya il ya quelques années
c'était il ya quelques années vous
saurez quand elle fait pendant plusieurs
années avec tous les acteurs de la
téléphonie donc là on reprend c'est un
petit peu sa main un peu différent
surtout quand le faire et qu'aurélien
donc c'est un mélange de be to be ebit
souci comment disait tout à l'heure et
on évite ou 6 et voilà est pas loin là
dedans on est ravi de faire se mélangent
pas son nom mais tout à fait
complémentaires en ce sens si on a des
visions un petit peu différente sur les
mêmes marchés et on veut vous apporter
cette diversité alors quelque chose
d'important de la soirée c'est le 10
décembre et ça se voit sera à la maison
de l'amérique latine donc à paris et
voilà donc on retourne à informer et
surtout aurélien aura l'occasion de
faire un compte rendu en images ces
soirées qu'il partagera les mouvements
sera les petits fours et champagne et
puis surtout la remise de prix donc on
fait ça va se faire en plusieurs temps
début novembre je vous annoncerai un peu
les catégories vous allez voter pour les
produits que vous vous laissez vous quel
est vraiment faire le vote et ensuite
vous allez remettre enfin je remettrai
voit on remettra on met c'est un peu
dans le cadre on remettra vos vos
récompenses directement aux
constructeurs opérateurs et toussa
toussa toussa et tout le monde et
ensuite il y aura effectivement un
reporting
après la soirée où on vous racontera
comment ça s'est passé on vous montre
tout son image et puis ça va être super
super super cool super intéressant et
puis vous aurez surtout le résultat des
votes parce que bien évidemment doit
garder confidentielles jusqu'au bout
vous comprendrez truc quoi devrais super
tout super événements et alors on vous
informera prochainement aussi des
catégories donc on va bien finir avec
catégorie on est en train de travailler
dessus il ya déjà un premier travail qui
est fait mais aulas parle aux quatre
oscars dont tous catégorie on a onze
prix orange à 11 prix
peut-être si on en a envie il ya un
grand prix du jury qui ressort on verra
il aura peut-être 12e mais pour
l'instant y atteint une limite sur les
longues nous voilà avec quoi faire un
bel événement donc rester dans le restez
connectés j'ai treize autres pouvoir
vous l'annoncer aujourd'hui parce que
c'est quand même un événement qui pour
nous tous cas est important je pense
qu'il va aussi être important dans
l'écosystème du smartphone des
opérateurs ça peut être super cool donc
voilà excellent titre l on a tout dit je
crois je n'ai pas mal à bientôt
merci à vous et à très bientôt portez
vous bien de tout temps bastia deux ans